Oh wow
Oh my goodness
I've never seen this one it's vampire Bob
Who is this handsome kid?
They're gonna love my gift way more than yours, just saying
Dash my man. Mahalo Keith! Jenny from black/pink Fellow citizens of Rome. Hey another powerful little sister
Zhu Jie I will never forget about you
Okay where is the pillow I was supposed to wrap?
Fine, you can have your pillow
Gaten? Yes? You doing okay there?
I'm trying my best
I did the thing where, you like, don't cut it
Wait, this is not enough
Stop stepping on my gifts
Who's the best rapper in the bunch? Probably Sadie. Definitely Sadie.
Honesty Sadie wraps presents the best. Cause she's very like, you know, she's perfect
on everything she does, you know, okay not like that!
Ohhhh! Sadie!
Sadie!
Happy holidays!
I think the best rapper is uh, I'm into Cardie B. And who do you think is the worst wrapper? Millie is the worst rapper.
I think the worst of wrapping Christmas presents is me but in a good way because I do it fast and efficient
I don't waste my time doing it one by one. I just throw them all in and then I wrap it
Look great. Oh wait we're wrapping? Dude what are you talking about? The best
It's also me because I do it very well
Can I just do a little improv message near the camera
I'd like to, to just wish everyone happy holidays
For Christmas for Hanukkah or Kwanzaa?
Whatever you want. Happy holidays. Happy holidays. Happy Holidays, Happy Holidays. Happy holidays
I'd be careful with that bat, I think it's the real one
I know, I know
I'll take that. There you go